i think like the most appropriate thing
to say to you is like bro
when i say bro
how exciting is it that the tracksuit
mafia got their own poster
like that was that that's one of the
things that blew us away we had so much
fun on the show and
and and the team that we built and the
tracksuit mafia main track supermarket
piarter and carlos um right away we
clicked and we went out to dinner we got
to know each other and it wasn't one of
those things where you needed to do a
bonding before he got set right right
when we started hanging out we were like
oh this is going to be so much fun and
the last thing we thought we were going
to get a poster just because marvel's so
secretive we didn't know what we were
doing like day to day what the script
was we would only kind of be seeing the
sides and so we were we were like you
know like if we if we if we make the
show cool like we are we going to be on
the cutting room floor or so we didn't
really have a lot of information and how
big the tracksuit mafia kind of was a
part of the show but the the the
pleasant surprise was that the fans
really took to our characters and and
really kind of really kind of pushed it
forward and where we got our own memes
and and and the poster came out which we
had no idea about so when we all saw it
at the same time we all were we're going
hey i
just stopped
so look that doesn't surprise me because
the chemistry uh between you guys is so
great how much fun is it playing a
baddie
oh it's the best i mean for me
personally i i don't i don't roll in
that kind of avenue i never have
so so i'm basically a mom's boy
but um and i got a dad that taught me
how to box so i kind of was like um play
both sides but the idea of playing
uh like a bat quote-unquote baddie it's
just so much fun because you just get so
much out of your own personal element
and you can just explore all those
different parts of you that um that this
type of character would go to but in
real life i would i never would so it
was it's really really fun to do
who is the most excited in your life to
know that you are part of the marvel
universe like who is so pumped for you
my brother my brother
my older brother collected comic books
like crazy and and i would always kind
of and he kept him in mint condition and
he would never let me touch them but i
would i would kind of see them behind
his back and slowly slip it in the thing
and when uh and when he i finally told
him that i what i was allowed to tell
him that i was apart going to be a part
of the mcu he was excited but then when
he actually saw the show like he was
like and he's a doctor so he's bragging
to me i brag about him all the time so
he's now he's bragging about me to his
co-workers so it's it's a good feeling
oh i love that all right well we have to
talk about this big kingpin reveal i
mean there's so much speculation i even
interviewed vincent d'onofrio a couple
of weeks ago and he was like
tight-lipped of course uh how exciting
was that for you
well
like i i got super fortunate there's a
there's a acting peer group in vancouver
where i'm at and there's uh john cassini
who kind of runs the whole thing and he
gets a special guest and he
knew vincent would come in and basically
does the course we pay he does the
course for free for a bunch of actors
and then he donates it to the acting
studio which i think is amazing and i've
been a fan of his from day one and so
this is before marvel actually was even
in the picture so i got to study with
with the great vincent opera who i think
is one of the best ever and then and
then months later i get cast in the show
but i can't say anything because i don't
know anything
and so hopefully during a twitter
exchange i can remind him that i took
his class and right before it and and
just to kind of be a part of the show
and be a part of almost his his type of
gang is uh it's just mind-blowing i mean
i feel so fortunate that's actually a
really cool story so full circle
yeah it came full circle when i told uh
my buddy john who runs a great like the
uh railtown it's just an amazing spot
and when i told him he was like this
makes no sense but it kind of makes
sense like this is how the world works
so yeah we were we're pretty happy about
it so i think it's safe to say a lack of
cox is this fantastic breakout star of
this series um you know you obviously
shared a lot of scenes with her uh
what what do you love about the dynamic
with your character in hers there's a
reason why you don't know her name is
because this is her first acting gig
right
she's never acted before first
she has never acted before i didn't know
that yeah that's how that's how amazing
this is so she the the character in in
the comic is
indigenous and deaf and so she is
actually indigenous and deaf
so they casted
like for the role they didn't have
someone pretending to be deaf to learn
sign language they cast it so authentic
to the role and for her to come in with
a translator never seen cameras like
this before at a stage like this before
and the performance that she puts on
she she is so not only is she just a
kind amazing human to to everybody
around her and her family came to visit
and she was just so stoked to be a part
of it but she did the work and and she
comes across like she's she's done this
her whole life and for us that have been
doing it for a while we're like are you
kidding me she's nailing this on her
first big shot this is awesome
so yeah and just to be a part of her
team and us kind of you know discuss
character and talk about you know the
hierarchy um and her understanding
backstory and yeah her getting the right
people to help her out um i honestly i
i'm so proud of her and for her to kind
of go on and be a part of the mcu is
something that's really special for
somebody that's been doing it as a life
goal but for her to drop into it and
still give it the same respect yeah and
own it but give it the same respect that
an actor that would like kill to have
that role and she kind of just was there
and and they got her like plucked her
out of nowhere and she still has the
respect for people around her and and
the role so that makes it really
exciting that's so cool are you on
social media
like watching everyone's reaction some
people like want to stay clear of that
you know and obviously there's such a
die hard fan base and then other people
love it because they want to see
everyone's reactions i'm i'm that guy i
love not only do i love seeing
everyone's reactions i love interacting
with i love interacting with the fans
like one one guy one guy tweeted um i'm
so not a fan of these tracksuit mafia
and it just kind of threw it out there
and i just happened to see it and i just
responded with um i i just responded
with your next bro
and then he goes
and then he responds goes i can't
believe what tracks who papi are
following me i love you guys like it
kind of just switched gears just
interacting and just having fun with it
and and and i i i was i'm on a project
right now where we shot um in antarctica
so
so this film that i'm doing right now
with anthony hopkins it's a sequel which
again is a dream because it's anthony
hopkins but our first location was
antarctica which is the
we made history by it's the first
hollywood scripted film to ever shoot in
antarctica so we were off the grid so i
had no for 14 days i had no cell service
because we were shooting this totally
off the grid because there's no service
and so to come back to almost like 800
messages and and tweets and and and
instagram stuff like to come back and be
able to read all that even though i
missed two weeks of the show was just
really it it was really heartwarming and
beautiful and i'm glad i made it back
for the finale that's on today on disney
plus and and just really really excited
to to just be a part of that whole
universe so my next question is going to
be what's it like being in antarctica
with anthony hopkins
well
[Music]
there it there are no words man like
like i got nothing like there was we had
one of the world's top ex
expedition leaders that that has crossed
antarctica to the south pole and he was
a part of our team to help guide us and
just
being there and he and and being at the
bottom of the world where the polls are
just kind of like there's an energy
there that's just it's you can't
describe it in the pictures and the
films that we're gonna show but to see
the landscape and to know there is no
way this was shot in manitoba this is
like the scope of this
this is actually antarctica and to be
the first film to be there um and make
history in that way it's just amazing
and rick dougdale is the director of the
film called zero contact it was his
brainchild and we have what's crazy is
that we have 12 more countries to go
which is a part of the whole idea of
being authentic to the script so we're
heading to cairo and machu picchu so
we're heading to some amazing spots but
the but the spot that was so remote was
antarctica and
uh uh sebastian copeland who was the
expedition leader kind of gave me some
advice of just saying look man if you
can find a moment just go to the edge of
camp and just just a little bit beyond
the flags and just be with the desert of
snow
it was so emotional because everything
goes through your brain of like you know
you're doing something special so
it was great but i did i did miss
hawkeye for two to wednesday so i wasn't
happy about that part of it
but it sounds like it's worth it sounds
like you made the right decision with
this project uh is there anyone who you
would love to work with like on your
bucket list because you've worked with
some really amazing people already
yeah i mean there's so much ben kingsley
is one that i would love to work with
and you know and there's a there's a
bunch of repeaters just because i love
the idea of being surprised like when i
worked with keanu reeves he had he had
this amazing reputation and then to
actually have it honored by our
interaction that we had and jason mamow
is the same way he's been my buddy for
for years so i love the fact that
you know people that i admire that i've
worked with it's more about working with
them again than it is a real bucket list
thing but um i'm i'm all about being
surprised and
being you know when anthony hopkins
first i've worked with him three years
ago i kind of i kind of fangirled where
i i
and it was it was weird because i i
wanted to counter the fan girls like
okay alex don't fangirl here he comes
don't fangirl don't fangirl be cool but
i played it too cool so when he came up
just introduced himself i i just i did
this he's behind me i did i went what's
up man
and then i went i am so sorry i'm just
like fangirling right now and then we
just hit it off and became friends
did you really call yourself out like
that
oh yeah right
yeah in a heartbeat i was like i am so
sorry because it was just
i just thought i it was when it left my
lips i was like you idiot you just
overcooled this no you called yourself
out so you redeemed yourself you're fine
yeah um yeah well hey congratulations
really nice getting to talk to you
hopefully i'll get to talk with you
again
i would love that yeah this is pretty
cool because people can also talk about
this online it's really fun seeing
everyone's reactions
so great thank you for having me i
really yeah so nice meeting you alex
that's so cool